this afternoon we have the great honor
of hearing directly from our next
president
please join me in welcoming the man who
started his political career career in
1970 on the new castle
county council went on to be senator for
the great state
of delaware and for 36 years and finally
as we all know served as the 47th
vice president of the united states help
me welcome
president-elect joe biden
hey everybody i hope that all of you and
your families and loved ones are
keeping safe during these hard days for
our nation
we're facing the darkest days of this
pandemic and our economy is still in
crisis
and recovering much too slowly in my
view we're experiencing a long overdue
reckoning on racial justice
and we have to take serious actions to
address the existential threat of
climate change
american cities are on the front lines
on all of these crises
you know you are the people in this
country look to first
for your leadership your guidance towns
cities larger cities you know i know
how hard it's been you know when we did
the recovery act
back when and when we first came into
office i
dealt with thousands of the folks in
your in small cities
and big cities and you are the place
where people go
their quality of life depends more on
what you're doing than anything else and
i know
how hard it's been coveted is training
your health care systems
burning out your healthcare providers
essential workers are putting their
lives and their health at risk
to keep your communities running but
you're not getting the support you need
to be able to keep paying your teachers
your police officers your firefighters
your first responders
providing them ppe keeping everyone safe
you know uh it's if we and the congress
has passed the money
it's passed the money that was designed
to do this
and it's not coming forward i know it
must be frustrating
yet in the face of these challenges
you've all stepped up
i want to thank you for being there for
your communities for the families who
are grieving and lost
loved ones you're there for the folks
who are worried about
they're going to be able to pay their
rent or find their mortgage payment
and all the proud americans who are
seeking food support
i've seen it you've seen those those
lines in your own cities
thousands of people lining up for the
first time in their lives
first time in their lives needing food
for thanksgiving
eating food day to day i want you to
know that my administration will have
your back i promise you
it didn't matter whether your city
supported me or didn't support me i
meant when i said
there are no red cities there are no
blue cities
only american cities american states
period i really mean that these are
american challenges
we have to meet them with one country as
one country
not as i said as red and blue states but
the united states
and vice president-elect harris and i
are committed to being real partners to
you
so we can coordinate a real nationwide
response
to these crises so i want to thank you
all for what you're doing
for your leadership comfort and support
you'll continue to provide for americans
as we face this pandemic
i know that our best days still lie
ahead i really believe that
and as president i'm going to work with
all of you
deliver to deliver for the american
people and i really mean that
like i said you know you're right on the
front lines
people probably literally are knocking
on some of your doors
your doors city managers
city mayors council persons
i want to thank you all you really are
doing a job
and you're not asking anybody when they
ask for help whether they're democrat
republican independent
you're stepping up i promise you i will
do that
and you have a seat at my table in the
white house
when i am sworn in i genuinely mean it
i generally mean it i wish all of
you and yours a safe and healthy
thanksgiving
and god bless you all and may god
protect our troops
thank you so much for that inspiring
refreshing message president-elect biden
your commitment to true partnership
with local leaders is so important and
we at national league of cities were
excited about
your appointment for julie rodriguez the
inter-government affairs director
will be working hand-in-hand with her
thank you again sir and as you
know why uh president-elect biden taken
the time to join us today's is extra
special because it's his birthday
so happy birthday president-elect
biden so all right my friends we have
come to the conclusion
of our final general session but we're
not finished
be sure now to join us at our annual
business meeting where we will elect our
new officers and adopt our municipal
policy guide for the coming year
if you are registered as your city or
state municipal league's voting delegate
please make sure to join us in the
annual business meeting for voting
delegates listed under
my agenda but if you're not a voting
delegate we invite you to attend a live
stream of the meeting that's
open to the public which can be found on
the full agenda tab
it has been truly an honor to have you
all join us virtually
can't wait to see you all again in march
may god bless and protect you thank you
so much for joining us
and looking forward to seeing you at the
biz annual business meeting
thanks again